we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got called
out by the Eggman for using a word he
claims his fake take a listen to what he
said dude you just had intimidate Ori
that Rand Paul's life having a loaded
gun under her frickin pillow look I have
even googled that crap yet but there's
no way intimidate Ori is a word I mean
you might mean intimidating I don't know
but it's not a word
you're not even the Native American not
even like Thomas Carr Native American
language how do you know more than I do
that cannot be a word I'm not even gonna
google it I know it's not a word yeah
what saying is timid Ettore that's crazy
talk I'd encourage the eggman next time
to google it because it turns out that
if you go to any dictionary you will
find that the word intimidate Ori is a
word it's an adjective the definition of
intimidate Ori is tending or intended to
intimidate which is exactly what I meant
by my use of it regarding Rand Paul's
wife the first known use of intimidate
Ori by the way for the language Wizards
the linguists be they cunning or
otherwise was around 1846 with the same
meaning that I gave tending or intended
to intimidate so you know eggman should
actually just look it up in the Internet
age isn't it easier to just do a little
Google search believe me a voice we're
calling David Pakman show voicemail I
agree I agree on the bonus show today
Sears once the world's biggest retailer
is now facing bankruptcy and I also want
to talk by the way about Best Buy in
this story if you'll allow it Pat I
recently read a very interesting article
about how best buy by all accounts
should be out of business but they're
actually doing really well because of
some particular things that they're
doing so as long as we don't get into
your Circuit City employment experience
I'll allow it to pass I may have to
mention that interested in passing
Greece has banned obese tourists from
riding donkeys that is just an unusual
but true story and we will also talk
about how in North Korea former NBA
basketball player Yao Ming has become
China's answer to Dennis Rodman what
does that even mean
I will explain all of these stories and
more on today's bonus show
www.davidpakman.com/membership s--
regardless of whether you're male or
female because we've got five that are
available to anybody and ten available
to women as designated by the donor
email me personally david at david
pakman.com and i will set you up with
one of those memberships and if you
don't want that or don't even know what
on earth I'm talking about you can just
make a pledge of five bucks a month or
more at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and then you'll get access to the
same world-famous bonus show